[Music]
before creation itself there were six
singularities
forged into Infinity stones
this is our first day here we are
Pinewood in Atlanta and it's it's
actually pretty unbelievable day one of
what promises to be a year of fun-filled
lensing I remember actually going to see
the first Avengers with one of my best
mates from home and I'd never have
dreamed that I'd ever be in one of these
movies let alone playing spider-man I
feel like I'm on top of the world
because this is just mind-blowing
what we always try to do at marvel
studios is we're building the cinematic
universe is look at the big picture how
can things relate across movies and
across years Avengers infinity war is
the culmination of the entire Marvel
Cinematic Universe as started in May of
2008 with the release of Iron Man 1 and
it really is an unprecedented
culmination of a series of films
interlinked together which it's time had
never been done before and for us the
important thing is making it all come
together we know they're going to face
Thanos we've been setting that up since
Avengers 1 how do you do that in a way
that is unexpected that pits the
Avengers against somebody who's more
powerful than anyone they faced and yet
make them completely unprepared to face
him well tear them apart which is why we
did Civil War before infinity war as we
were conceiving in an executing civil
war the end of that movie was very much
a setup for what these movies would be
we always had that sense of that
tony is not talking to Steve the
Avengers are basically a name with
nobody in it the world is vulnerable
Tony
senses his greater threats approaching
and so he is doing everything in his
power to keep deer safe
thanos shows us why he's the biggest the
best the baddest villain that we've ever
had and the most frightening villain
that the Avengers have ever faced the
most exciting part is the incredible
roster of well developed characters and
it's going to create a really
combustible exciting massive scale
adventure you know that we're onto
something within the studio when we hit
upon an idea or we see a piece of
concept art and all of us in the room go
this is cool and an Avengers infinity
war the Avengers will meet the guardians
of the galaxy
because of what Marvel is because of
what they have done over the last ten
years
these next two Avengers films would be
an event like no one has ever seen on
film before
oh I needed to me time and I came to
Australia and that's when I moved in
with Daryl hello
and here we are oh it's a nice flat